these vultures have lined up to Feast on
and profit from the confusion of
innocent kids confusion that these same
vultures have intentionally fostered in
the minds of our youth they create the
identity crisis and then they monetize
it these kids are put on so-called
puberty blockers to chemically castrate
them drugs that by the way have been
given to sex offenders to chemically
castrate them and before the age of 18
many kids will undergo surgery such as
double mastectomies one of the most
basic truths is that children who are
confused about their identity need
guidance and love and Clarity they don't
need hormone injections and scalpels our
kids cannot protect themselves we need
to do it that's our job as adults and
everybody who's remained silent on this
issue is culpable in what is happening
to our kids many members of the media
who have not demonstrated the slightest
bit of skepticism as the medical
establishment has just told us over the
years that it's life-saving care to
castrate a child the majority of the
media that just goes along with that
doesn't ask one skeptical question